[Music]
joining me today is a British media
personality a columnist and author and a
businesswoman who apparently triggers
everyone Katie Hopkins and finally
welcome finally I'm here thank you very
much for having me yeah it's my pleasure
we were going to do this about a year
ago and then something happened
something I know I got sent somewhere to
cover something else or god knows what
happened but I was supposed to be here
but finally I'm sitting in your studio
and I'm thrilled to be here and I love
your studio it's very posh Thanks Oh
posh that you are British
I am I miss purchases they come yes all
right we have a lot to talk about
you're here I saw mostly to do the
Reuben report that's why you're in LA
but also you don't let it fall you do
want to flip something like a month and
a half literally I like wake up we go
yeah yeah yeah you did politican you've
been around all of these political
pundits and the screaming people and the
parsing nut bags and all of that stuff
yes I can tell just in the little brief
moments that we spend together you love
this stuff I know that we love it I love
it and the thing I love most I speak to
the organizer last night for Politico
and he's a regular guy actually a Brit
as well as it turns out the thing I love
best about Panetta Khan is not even the
people of the stage or the panelists or
the people that might think they're
important the people that made political
for me were the people chewing this
enormous line of people just queueing
round and round and round to queue up
for whatever it was they were passionate
about over the road behind the fencing
there was a little group of people who
would Trump supporters with their van
with a little Trump mask just there to
kind of go liberals we're here with
opposite the road to scare you and I
love that I love the people particularly
Americans are super engaged with
politics at the moment they're super
engaged with the process they're willing
to commit funds to it and I think that's
what Trump is also blessed America with
is reinvigorating this enthusiasm for
getting involved I think that's a great
thing yeah so one of the things that
I've been saying about Club and I I did
not vote for Trump I didn't support
Trump but I had Trump we can drop all
off you you can talk all about it I'm
here with goodwill for you listen that's
why we're here yeah I don't worry about
yeah it's doing a book Trump
man I was going to tell you how but uh
but what I think that is better than
anything else is that Trump has some of
my guests have said he's drove a truck
through the store in my my metaphor is
that he's taken the chessboard and
thrown it up that everything is such a
mess right now that there is a new
enthusiasm there is fertile ground and
all of that and I think that's far more
valuable in many ways than this policy
or that policy or anything I'll say yeah
so - and anyway your version of a mess
might be that somebody just got fired
after only 11 days in a job or maybe
your version of a mess is that someone
else had to leave and someone leaked and
some almost mouthing someone said rude
words but for me coming from the UK and
London you know a mess for us is a
country that is not going to enforce
brexit that we voted for 52% of us voted
for we may not ever see that and mess
for me as in 24 hours since I left the
UK there were four stabbings to acid
attacks and the riot and then of course
we've come off the back of a summer
where we've been run down by trucks
blown up on bridges and stabbed with
hunting knives when we're out trying to
have a meal with our family so your
version of a mess in terms of a
political system and organized chaos is
is quite different to my reference of a
mess load understand is a mess yeah so
you would really argue that the mess
you're dealing with even though for the
people that are triggered or upset by
crime that your mess is much worse yeah
in many ways you know I look to America
as kind of hope like inspiration hope
you've got someone tough in the White
House that's determined to get things
done you've got a whole group of people
who believe they've been forgotten which
to me is the BRICS appears it's the same
it's the rest of UK at the rest of
America that isn't California or isn't
New York the rest of America got their
voice heard and that really speaks to
the bricks a tear in me where the rest
of the UK finally got to say to London
no you think you're smart you think
you're liberal you don't live amongst
the migration you don't live with what
we live with and you're going to listen
to us and I think Trump did that and I
love that he does it yeah tell me a
little bit about your where your
politics came from like growing up and
were you always into politics
News here's what happened to me I didn't
have my father ask that on a very
regular basis my condom Bellamy Babli
yeah my bad what happened I bet my
father said if I marry anyone else I'm
out of the world like he has some rules
for me and those are his basic rules now
it's no more weddings ever for me I'm
already on husband too but I call him
like my current husband just to keep him
like a little bit anxious build anxious
and what happened to me I don't know so
I was just a regular kid I went to a
convent school can blame the nun
somewhere in there yeah and then I kind
of like debating and then I went into it
so I was army industry within Manhattan
for ten years in the East Village I
lived loved and and then from there I
went on to the British version of The
Apprentice and it seems that from there
I kind of segwayed into media I had no
plan to do that I had no desire to be
media and commentary but after The
Apprentice kind of media just sort of
took me up and took me over and then
there became this kind of little space
for someone who was prepared to say it
really straight who didn't necessarily
want to be liked who doesn't have an
agent or a publicist or a legion of PRS
trying to pretend that I'm something
that I'm totally not I am just this and
and I think that's where I sort of found
my niche and I think that the more I
live amongst London and the more I work
amongst a liberal establishment the
elite the left-wing the more actually my
platform grows because people see that
the list of things we can't say is
longer than the list of things we can
and when their silence they kind of look
to me and say we're at least she's still
speaking and that's what really annoys
the lefties is the more they try and
shut things down silence me the bigger
my voice and it really annoys them and I
say to them you know you are
Frankenstein and I am your monster yeah
really annoys them and I love that flow
it's like my low when I had my loan
before he was my low when people were
just kind of finding it I had my
headline in his honor he told me you
like this hair done I like it's not my
low or don't like no it is not it is
yeah well I think you have more than
hair just in common because he kept
saying to me right at the beginning when
I had him on really before he had gotten
we're close to the Milo that we now know
he said well look if these guys want to
beat me I'll tell you how to beat me
don't show up stop protesting me bla bla
bla
you know he wanted attention yeah and
yet they kept doing the wrong thing do
you find consistently that your
intellectual opponents or the people
that don't like you that they just they
won't even do the work to sort of beat
your ideas that it's just about
silencing of it yes exactly right so
there's become smarter you know watch
them they're like amoeba or like some
kind of virus or disease and I watch
them evolve so they sort of worked out
that antibiotic and how to beat that and
now they've evolved to get the next one
so their latest iteration of themselves
is to go at your commercial sponsors or
to go at your boss or to go at your
boss's boss or to try and take you down
that way and that's upsetting to me not
because I'll lose platforms because I'll
accept that that's no problem it's that
I would much rather they were sat in
that chair opposite me and take me down
because you're smarter than me take me
down because your arguments are better
than mine take me down because okay you
didn't know Trump was going to win I did
okay you didn't call brexit I did but
don't paint me down because I happen to
be right you were wrong be better than
me and I don't see that yet but I do see
the way that groups of the establishment
of the left can influence commercial
sponsors and of course that will remove
a platform any day of the week yeah it's
funny that the first thing he said we
only only talked for a couple minutes
before we started but we're talking
about how I built this thing yeah I left
the eBay there's this craziness now with
there's some stuff with patreon that I
did an interview with earlier in the
week and there's all sorts of D
monetization things and all that now
you're working for a mainstream ya
application but you still have those
same pressures of mobic are they going
to come for your job or they go or what
else are they going absolutely and you
know of course or so if I'm a Daily Mail
columnist there is the reputation of
mail online Daily Mail calm that sits
with me they can go after that they can
use communities of interest you know I'm
so pro-israel Pro dues I want to be I'm
an ambitious to myself I'm not one but I
want to be one when I grow up I have
this nose but who built you yeah like I
want to be a Jewish like that's my life
goal I got born as a nose and yet still
don't get to be Jewish which is like
totally unfair
and yet randomly these lefties will
sometimes find a group of maybe rabbis
that are part of their hope not hate you
know we have hope not hate yes and then
they use the bar both about buying your
biggest fan so they will use people to
try and influence my bosses the paper to
try and suggest that their association
with means in some way harming their
brand whereas in reality of course all
it takes is for me to put up a column
but then is the most read column that
week and it's so infuriating because
therefore I'm useful to the paper yeah
so how much of your political ideology
which I think I want to get into how
much of it is based either just purely
in like politics and you know the things
behind philosophy versus just life yeah
just the least it's just like well screw
these guys who got everything wrong and
they're still training and preaching and
trying to take my job in the rest of it
yeah I mind I think my stuff definitely
comes much more from life so it hasn't
been that I've just like I'm kind of I
don't know deke but I kind of watched a
lot of news or watch a lot of
politicians and then I have something to
say about that I don't feel that way at
all
what I feel it's much more it's much
more authentic to me it's much more
inside of me the things I feel so the
reason I wanted to be in the forces you
know I went to Sandhurst I was sponsored
by the Intelligence Corps through
University a great surprise to most
people who like to say that I'm stupid
as one of my labels is that I wanted to
defend my country I wanted to fight for
my country I was going to be the first
female general you know I'm a proud
Patriot too that's in me and then when I
went into business you know the idea
that the free market is the answer that
small state limited state is the answer
to be a true libertarian you will not
describe how you can spend your money
what your healthcare comes from how you
will you know spend your time I think we
need limited state that comes from a
lifetime in business and then certainly
operating with people like things like
The Apprentice or whatever just watching
human nature watching how easy how
quickly you can work someone out what
they're like what they think how they
work how you can take them down I love
all of that and that kind of built into
my debate stuff all the stuff I do on TV
where it's easy to see a weakness and
you can just take people out on it yeah
so is that part of when people criticize
you and Russia says this she taught you
know even yeah
I got less this time which i think is a
good sign that would the first time I
said I was having you on again about a
year ago I got always had she's racist
she's a banshee yeah this time I think
maybe I sent the tweet out of an odd
time at all times well you never know
and I always am really gonna know awake
at 2:00 in the morning you know it's
funny I know it would be virtually
impossible to offend you but I was if I
was to say well I tweeted signing out
that I'm having one unless people are
upset that actually might offend you
because you like maybe I'm not maybe I'm
not knew I really know I think things
have changed and alone I think that
shows that that reason in a way is
working because people are getting less
outraged by hearing some some common
sense stuff I look at your Twitter
sometimes I'll go and maybe she said
that in a little way that I wouldn't
have said it is or this yes just not
exactly how I operate up but I never
from what I've seen I've never seen
blatant racism or anti-semitic stuff or
long before he's not a word but I really
haven't seen that no I did smell that
show so are you not a bigoted racist
equipment well I don't you know I I say
go for it like if you like labels go for
it if you can have a fist on to
something and make me it if that's your
hobby go crazy like you probably at home
if we still live with your mom your
problem has spare room your keyboard is
definitely sticky maybe give it a wipe
sometime if you're really bored with
your life like Newton he's probably
still like flush your teeth with your
own toenails and eat your own earwax I
don't mind but you're going to call me a
racist ass artist love that one and
Islamophobe or whatever I believe I'm
none of those things I can show you and
demonstrate to you through argument
through what I do through the stories
that I've told the columns I've written
I'm none of those things I understand
that if you lack the vocabulary and the
intellect to be able to take me down
with an argument you think a label will
suffice what you will have seen over 10
years of throwing those labels at me is
that I still haven't really shut up yeah
and I think the other thing people see
is they do see what you see is that I
get so much sort of thrown at me so much
regression or people imagine that I get
assaulted in the street I don't but that
people say I'm going to come and rape
you with a machete you know okay good
but it won't fit
yeah fine you know I'm gonna come and
lock you in your car and set fire to it
along sure you know whatever makes you
feel good you lack the language to be
able to articulate the way that your
cross with me then I understand that
you'd look cross with me because I have
a different view to them
I don't accept many of the things that
have seen as the tick box of right
answers that you have to have in the UK
I don't accept that we should just have
open borders I don't accept that we
should pander to Muslim as a and Islam
as a religion
I don't accept for example I was
speaking yesterday with a bunch of a
roomful of feminists I mean you could
just hear them just kind of melting when
I spoke but you know my challenge to
them is where are you where are you
beminat sees when women have got burgers
on when they've got three you know
they're allowed to take what happens are
allowed to take three wives where are
you for the Muslim rape squads in the UK
I don't hear you talking about that
where were you when in Cologne on New
Year's Eve over 1200 sexual assaults I
don't hear you
same with black lives matter went to
debate yesterday the woman stood up the
first thing she said do we all agree
that black lives matter and the room
went crazy and it's like you have got
wheat we really a point where someone
was saying black lives didn't matter is
that is that the best you've got who
bumped into the niece of Martin Luther
King in the foyer on my way to come and
see you and asked her you know what's
your view on black lives matter and she
said they are just paid protesters and
they need to just stop yeah she gave us
identity files exactly that's from the
niece of Martin Luther King and you go
she's probably got a point
and I think this identity politics has
to stop i watch the [ __ ] marches in
Washington when I went to the
inauguration of Trump best day of my
life and I went suppose she marches to
see what they were about and you know
they were just home pathetic so some
women have banners with save the
environment some had banners with black
lives matter some that were vegetarians
and wanted to tell you about that and
others were like here because my [ __ ]
is made of steel like make up your mind
while you here you don't know you're
just a coalition
of weakness and victimhood be better
like women need to be better than that
and they're not a women have never been
more disappointing I can it's obvious to
me that not allowed gets to you but to
me if I were you
that would get to me as a woman that
that just by saying all these things the
mainstream woman hood hood not at least
whatever maybe okay so right now weights
master code runs of which is what anyone
a collective noun is for witches but
it's that which is I think yes but that
thing that they would turn on you I mean
whether they like your politics or not
you're a strong independent woman with a
track record and a resume and all of
those things so you'd think there would
be a little they might say yeah we don't
like the way she talks about this but
you think there'd be a little room in
this white umbrella but the purpose
their whole purpose is to get rid of
people hmm absolutely and I quite like
the idea they can't I like the idea that
I'm a woman so men find a bit tricky to
directly challenge me unless they're
threatening to you know kill me on
Twitter and women find me really awkward
because I am one and yet I don't say the
things they need it to say so you can
see the women in the room look at me
going but she sort of is a woman but
she's not supporting endless maternity
leave she's not supporting the fact that
we should have all-female shortlist she
won't buy into the idea that we should
definitely have equal pay all time she
won't buy and xxx at equal treatment all
you have to say is say that and it means
something if you listen to what the
women's marching and the women's groups
say although words come out but I still
hear nothing they mean nothing you say
to them so what's come from the [ __ ]
marches the women's marches what have
you achieved tell me some definitive
outcomes from the women's marches
nothing nothing it's just nothing and so
what will you advise women to do rise up
rise up as all you hear what rise up
where go where
what are you rising up for what are you
achieving achieve nothing because they
have no clear aim no strategy and no way
of delivering it and I think that's very
disappointing where do you think that's
worse do you think that's worse in
Britain or in the United States that
that intersectional thing because we
know it's pretty terrible here but I
suspect it's probably pretty close I
think it's probably pretty close I think
it's I think so usually what happens in
America comes to us I
whatever you guys are up to whether it's
taking masses of prescription drugs
eventually we'll catch up and do the
same either
yeah thank you and if you get kind of
chronically obese eventually all of
Britain will follow that we do have
others yeah yeah I'm not here to like
though I guess I would go around I would
like to apologize for America now but I
do think as things like the way that
we've divided ourselves by these groups
of victims and the way you get ahead on
the left is by being a bigger victim and
the other victim or less well
represented or somehow made to feel like
you were a minority group that is not
unique to America I think we suffer from
it I think Hillary Clinton was the kind
of you know she was the sort of flag
bearer for that she just waved the flag
if you're a victim so yourself as a
victim minority then go to Clinton you
know and that's why obviously she lost
that's why she had no cohesive policies
that I rather remember and but it that's
definitely playing out in the UK young
people the first thing they identify
with isn't their country or necessarily
a political party it's what their
weakness is and how they can be more
weak than the next person so that they
own the victim status and that is tragic
so outside of the the people like you
that are outspoken talking about and
kind of being fun about inner you know
how do you fix the system I mean how do
you get the education system to go being
a victim is not something that you want
to do later in life like how you
actually do concrete steps to fix
something so I kind of commit to doing
two or three talks mums inside of
schools or colleges that will allow me
in and we would appreciate that window
is ever narrower also my main following
on Twitter so I have got eight hundred
thousand to to follows whatever that my
main following is actually very young
people there's also the oldies such as
social seniors this kind of hold onto
minatom nostalgic way like I represent
what Britain used to be i but actually
it's the young people that follow and
the young people that email me to say
you know you I can't say what you say I
can't I can't even I'm not allowed to
think the things you think but I love
that you do it I love that you - I'm
holding on to you because they're in
schools and colleges where they're being
brainwashed just as you are here with
your campuses and they can no longer say
any of the things that they would want
to say
you don't have stories from kids that
were in politics class that says
thinking of a caller to my radio show
who a mother that her son said that he
supported Trump and eventually he was
bullied out of that politics class even
and told by their lecturer that he
should have less radical thoughts you
know I know primary school that handed
out Clinton Mints in the playground the
night before in Britain you know they're
like literally literally handed out
mints with Clinton on so that the kids
would know Clinton was the right answer
you know we had kids at age four and
five who had to raise their hands if
their parents voted for breakfast and
they were made to feel silly and went
home and said oh you know we were made
to feel silly in class because you were
the ones that voted brexit so and after
Trump got in our school children were
sent home and told in primary schools
you'll go home tonight and your parents
will be crying and your parents will be
very upset because the wrong person won
and in this school we don't support hate
and they're allowed to teach that and
then is a very curious thing as well as
we're trying to embrace this kind of
idea of multiculturalism and you know
we're all equal and it's great that we
have Muslims in our classes that
therefore means with Trump comes up with
something labeled a Muslim ban Trump
equals hate and the school takes that as
permission to teach an entire generation
of young people Trump equals hate and
that I find that very hard that the left
tried to own the word hope and they try
to leave hate for everybody else so that
I become I hate preacher excites me
crazy yeah you give me a lot there okay
so all right what so let's talk about
Islam because I don't know if you know
this but a lot of people are talking
about it you're talking about it a lot
so how much of this it's hard for me
sometimes when I follow certain people
on Twitter to figure out how much of
this stuff is actually real versus just
sort of weak you know if everyone and
I'm not going to use specifically but
just people that cherry-pick now really
focus on it yeah so you know we hear
about these rape groups now in England
and that there were major cover-ups we
hear about these no-go zones we hear
about plenty of the street preachers and
what's happening in the mosques and all
this stuff
I've tried incredibly hard for the years
that I've been doing this show to
separate the ideas of Islam which is a
set of ideas that should be criticized
anyway you could criticize the ideas
that are Judaism buddy ideas in
Christianity or the idea that our
capitalism or anything else have cooked
versus Muslims who are people the vast
majority who want the same exact things
that you want and I want and everybody
else how big of an issue do you think
this this battle between the ideas of
Islam and the West is or did I even
frame that properly no I think it's fair
the way you frame it and I think it
would be a great thing if we were able
to in our daily lives I'm talking about
in the UK if we were able to separate
those two things out nice and neatly so
that it was about Islam and the ideology
and a criticism of that versus regular
Muslims living in the UK many of whom
were working very hard many of them have
been here for generations and just want
to crack on and do the same as the rest
of us which is look after our families
worked hard and try and be vaguely
healthy and and happy as much as we can
but I think the problem for us by the
way we could be a lot better about that
argument right here in America - yeah
it's not unique to you guys because I
know it all the time and still get
thrown in with the people yeah it's not
doing that no but I think in the UK the
problem we're trying to have that kind
of educated approach in that
differentiation of those two positions
is that when we live amongst it so much
and the attacks are so relentless it's
hard so as you're walking across if I
think now even if I'm walking across
Westminster Bridge to the House of
Commons you know the fact that there are
these concrete bowlers up but now
separate people on pavements from the
roads you know when we go to certain
junctions now there's concrete bollards
so that trucks can't drive into you when
you're crossing I think that we live
amongst that so much that there's a fear
of the acid attacks and the police have
just been putting out what to do in the
instance of an acid attack what to do
and this is kind of a new one literally
yes so the new sort of the evolution for
us that was the terror attack especially
across Rama Dam in the summer that sort
of peak terror for us we have the
Manchester bomb as well then we have the
police saying you know you run you hide
you tell run hide tell that's the
message from the police so that was
pushed out and of course that goes
against everything inside of me that
says no you chase them you fight them
you try your best you die try it now
that would be
more likely advice I want to hear and
there was a few people one Millwall
football supporter who did precisely
that he fought those attackers with
their knives and he got taken apart but
he survived but anyway run hide tell
that feels wrong that's not British to
me and now we've got the latest police
advice which is for acid attacks because
the latest is to come up on a moped
squirt sulfuric acid and take people out
that way and the acid attacks are sort
of you know whatever it says it's this
it's rinse its repeat it's something
cover and it's weird to me that we live
in a time where that's our police advise
is about how to cope with terror and
acid I find it really hard then to
differentiate right let's be a sensible
philosophical debate about Islam versus
I need a concrete bowler to get over
that bridge and here's my advice for
terror and I also think you know we have
surveys done 52 percent of Muslims in
the UK believe homosexuality should be
illegal 52 percent of the Muslims live
you know and the level of support for
terror attacks from Muslims living in
the UK is very high and then for example
when the grooming gangs attack you know
we have that in so many of our cities
they are coordinated they are networked
they are devastating and they see white
girls my daughters as trash we don't see
many Imams ever standing outside the
courts to just say not in the name of
our religion and I would have liked to
see that more I'd like to see feminists
also saying this is not right but I
don't hear that there seems to be a
silence on the left about all of that so
I think you've already answered this but
what do you think that I delight I mean
half a billion guests I had to talk
about this strange alliance between
feminine feminism and Islam and there
there is an alliance between two things
that should by all accounts be
completely at odds with each other yeah
so in on the left for me it seems to me
there is a very clear hierarchy of
things you accept so you accept on the
left
first of all multiculturalism like that
is your bedrock that's the foundation of
everything that's the number one thing
you have to accept and then things fall
under that in a hierarchy that we can
argue about
so maybe LGBT maybe black of probably
that less matter goes about that you
could put the environment somewhere this
is a hierarchy so when it comes to
my phobia in the Islamic community the
Muslim community it's still
multiculturalism still takes precedent
and that's why you have the silence
there's a thought vortex where they
can't possibly stick up for you no or
reject or denounce the idea that it's
not acceptable to be homophobic in the
UK because multiculturalism and respect
for the Muslim faith is higher on their
hierarchy of thinking it's a bit like
Maslow's hierarchy right it's all new
hierarchy of thought but if it was
Christians with those exact same
believes you would say that they are a
bunch of homophobe
but whatever reason the hierarchy
Christian comes much low and in fact
just last night I don't know what time I
crawled into bed after political I think
it's 3:30 or morning don't tell my
father yeah I'm 42 and but so I had an
email from someone asking for people
email me when they need things to be
heard or they feel so frustrated they
know that I will can help give them a
voice says I wanna email me because I'll
police very much now pushing reporting
of hate crime because they are driven to
do that through their policing strategy
is to push people towards to reporting
hate crime which of course why see hate
crime go up and they are kind of
rewarded on achieving hate crime figures
as part of their reporting anyway hate
crime reporting is very big in the UK
police departments are pushing it about
the right about the right wing not not
really about left or if you've had hate
maybe someone threatened to rape you
with a machete
doesn't matter matter but even if you go
on to one of the police forces I don't
want to misquote it I think it might be
best picture I'd need to double check
but when you go on and you try and log a
hate crime Christianity isn't even there
so it allows you to say your religion
whether you're a Buddhist whether you're
Muslim whether you're whatever
Christianity is not even on the list and
I think that says something huge about
the way Christianity is perceived in the
UK is not even being relevant enough to
have the akat agree on a drop-down menu
anymore yeah and what's odd is that
these things are now truly becoming
systemic because wasn't there a story
just about a month ago that the BBC
specifically was telling white people
to applied a certain job yeah so that's
something I've reported about for a
while so creative access the company is
called we managed to or I ran something
from the Daily Mail eventually their
funding was stopped for a while that
they are back their funding source they
have found a new source of funding like
I say these these viruses tend to evolve
to overcome I see myself as the anti
bacterial antibiotic but they evolve and
they come back to creative access
creative it really is the only character
it's available in any color as long as
it's not white right like all good vans
and I think if you're black minority
ethnic you can apply and one of the
interesting things as well it's always
for positions where no qualifications
are required either so it's literally a
free job for you the only thing you
cannot be is white and that is to most
positions for the BBC and it's linked
intrinsically through the establishment
so that they're getting more
representation of the sorts of faces
they want what do you make of the
intentions of these people so I'm with
you I hear you obviously most of my
audience hears you I'll go edit they've
been trying to fight this leftism you
know I told you beforehand I mean I used
to be a lefty and now I realize that
liberalism in the way that I view it has
nothing to do with being on the left but
I try not to impose everyone else both
on the road to Damascus and other fellow
like moment and you saw the like yeah
exactly so although I don't know that
I'd be welcome in Damascus well we'll
see but I think what point is that that
I try not to impugn everyone's motives
what do you think of the motives of
these people when they sit there in that
boardroom at this company and they're
doing all this you think this is just
misguided craziness or are there people
that truly are trying to do what I'm not
even sure so there's two thoughts I have
one I don't like to imagine is true and
the other one is that it is just the
correct thought the approved mind think
in the UK in terms that hierarchy of
thinking the approved mind think is
multiculturalism the BBC achieves
funding if it takes its multiculturalism
and multicultural objectives and as we
look to see how that maps out through
the things that we see we read we watch
we see more and more of the
that we're supposed to accept so that's
my that's my surface level
interpretation it's correct groupthink
and it's approved think my more sinister
interpretation that I don't like to go
near because it sends me down to the
tinfoil hat brigade and it makes make
very concerned is that it's part of a
wider approved and Soros backed movement
of people that is accept that the world
is changing accept mass migration of the
third world to the third this is when
when I go extremely talks about the
globalists right now yeah dad that fair
region of this yes which and I watch and
I and I try and do the thing you talked
about so I do try and discipline myself
I always ask myself what would someone
else say what would something that hated
me say what would my all of my husband
say like my husband is the opposite of
me he's known as lovely Mark II wears
off he's got an earring he votes labor I
said I would leave the country if Labour
got in he went straight down to that
polling station and voted labour world
so I think myself what would mark say I
tread try at but my point is I think
that the sorts of people that talk about
globalization the saw respect takeover
of the first world of Europe I believe
that maybe the true interpretation of
why this is being forced through the
establishment and I see that in all
different ways so I have traveled to
Sweden and seen and been through no go
Malmo through the no-go zones and seeing
women that are too frightened to go out
at night because it's terrifying there I
just came back from Libya and the Med
watching and plotting on their satellite
tracking data as well as standing at the
ports interviewing individuals to watch
the NGO ferries leave watch them the
tugboat come out so the NGO Clare he
goes over the tugboat comes out from the
Libyan shore drops something in the
water and goes back and then the NGO
boats all came back two and a half
thousand migrants into Sicily during the
week that I was there I watched this I
see these faces coming to us through
creative access where only black people
are acceptable and then I also see that
the mayor's the mayoral positions in the
UK which you can it's much easier to get
a mayor in that you
specifically wants to get the the way
that the Muslim mayor's in the UK are
spreading and the power is starting to
spread we have a Muslim heir as you know
in London that's when I go down the
tinfoil hat route but I start to think
perhaps if that is true perhaps it is
actually a much bigger strategic
globalist plan that is about taking over
Western Europe yeah and you know I have
one across Aegon's books over there
who's my favorite scientist of all time
and one of my favorite thinkers and he
would as I quoted all the time
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence so a lot of the
stuff that you're talking I think about
a lot of that except I plenty against to
think about it and then you know at the
other part of me wants that that
evidence but perhaps you just don't get
it in that well I think you can find you
find not the big picture evidence but
you can find small pieces of the puzzle
and in a way that's what I've spent I
suppose the last 12 18 months doing it's
just going to the jungle in Calais and
watching the trucker's you know under
tea guess watching the migrants get on
the backs of trucks spending 48 hours in
a truck seeing truckers have their path
blocked by trees being felled to the
migrants could get on the lorry going to
the Med gesturing at your world map
people wandering over there somewhere
the world map being on the Med don't if
it is over there but and to watch the
NGO ferry boats arriving that are also
funded through you know ways we can
track the funding to see these pieces to
go to Sweden where the Liberals want to
tell you it's all fine but actually you
go to no-go Malmo and I'm the only girl
and I got told to go suck your mum you
know because I was even daring to be out
after five o'clock at night and you
start to piece together these bits of
the jigsaw and you start to see that
maybe that picture does add up to
something quite a bit darker than you
might like to think it's almost too
sinister to go there
because you wonder then as I'm a mom
I've got three children they are 12 11
and 8 you do then wonder what does that
mean for the country that you believed
in so passionately you wanted to be in
the military to defend it so it's inside
me it's a burning anger standing
watching those boats ferrying migrants
varying men knowing that they're worth
45 euros a head to the Mafia that run
them it's an anger in me that we're
watching this happen
we've just seen Matt chrome in France
just buy up all the Formula One hotels
that sounds quite jazzy they're really
rubbish well that's how I know they're
called formula R but they're not at all
formula there was a really rubbish hotel
chain we probably can't say there are
let me now so anybody else know so I
think let's imagine you wouldn't go to
the formula hotels I remember going to
them when I was doing French exchange
trips you know they put kids in them
yeah Mac corners just brought them up
and he will now turn those hotels into
homes for the migrants and that's what
Italy has done so I was at a hotel for
migrants in Italy last week and so
another country goes like it's just that
the pattern is adding up the picture is
adding up and it scares me
[Music]
you
you